[Musique]
je me souviens de la ryder cup 2016 et
il s'obstine nous sommes le dernier jour
des parties d'entraînement le jeudi au
trou numéro 7 sur le green
il y a
rory mcilroy justin rose henrik stenson
partie d'entraînement sont sur le green
hill pote le pâté assez long de mètres
environ dirais-je et le 1er rac le trou
et dans parmi les spectateurs une voix
s'élèvent et dit ce n'est pas la ligne
le deuxième poste j'ai oublié lors de
2ème joueur portait la même voie crios
ips que le trou était raté ce n'est pas
la ligne le troisième poteau rate à
nouveau et la même voie dit ce n'est pas
la ligne - je l'aurais rentrée et
stetson agacé par cette voie qui les
ridiculise un petit peu tous les cas les
chambres font la foudre trouve le joueur
la personne qui a hurlé comme ça l'amène
sur le green pose là bas lui tant
qu'auteur et à ce moment là justin rose
arrive en courant sort un billet de 100
dollars prend until le plante devant la
balle donc l'enjeu du peuple qui sera
jouée 700 dollars
[Applaudissements]
et le spectateur ce mail address pets et
rots la bague
donc vous imaginez la foule en délire
les embrassades les joueurs qui ont
signé le billet de 100 dollars et ce
gars qui est sans doute devenu le
golfeur le plus heureux du monde
[Musique]